all right so I'm coming in and
starting the move there what I don't
want to do is I'm going to non-contest
here okay so this way come out you see
that started going here and then coming
now if the knife floats
no
right when he hits one go around it
and then always the basic principle is
check at the elbow check into the body
you see that don't open this up you're
going to get the other side rotating to
you okay so as I'm coming in for that
I'm going to flank there's your Nico
disarm boom and your redeeming towards
the back of the bottom so
okay let's just get those basic
principles and I I advice uh
some more athleticism to what you're
doing okay you're kind of like in these
weird hey do you guys see that okay so I
have my athleticism I can kick right
boom and I have my contact do you feel
that in your center right I'm not over
here and I'm not this touching here
so as
as okay so I'm cutting on his Center you
see his Center lower and I touch on his
Center as I'm coming along and then
always go to the back so you're back in
front here so I just want you to get a
tactical Awareness on that you're going
to get to the back
not in the front where he's gonna need
you okay so your home there's your
adhesion around in the center
inner Center into his Center and pull in
the back okay let's try it again so
crying go into where his weight is
home and not aware
I am
trying to get his weight because I want
to check his height okay
check this height
so my Center is going to drop the cheese
gonna sink okay
so he grabs
[Music]
okay let's try it
okay let's skip
okay
he'll come back in I want my Athletics
fancy come cracking
um
[Music]
I'm Gonna Keep moving under him
so if your partner is not able to do the
fall then you're just gonna get here
under him
okay let's go
down into his body to cut
all right so here
we want to understand
the Bobby lock
concept
okay so down check
we need to take that into edema not yet
so if you you can say it a little but
you're going to enter into that block
so part of me I'm going to exaggerate it
part of me is locking the hip
and at the same time the other part is
on the head
check that arm inside oh that's it here
boom here lock patch your arm here
here's your break
[Music]
okay let's try